[Música]
en chile la cámara de diputados aprobó
la acusación constitucional contra el
presidente sebastián piñera por el caso
dominga revelado en los papeles de
pandora la sesión se extendió por más de
20 horas hasta que fue aprobada con 78
votos a favor 67 en contra y 3
abstenciones con este paso los diputados
dieron luz verde así entonces para el
proceso juicio político contra el
mandatario que ahora tendrá que pasar a
discusiones en el senado pero que en
esta cámara no cuenta con los apoyos
necesarios para poder salir adelante la
pregunta ahora es cómo impactará esta
decisión a las elecciones que se
realizan en menos de dos semanas y para
ello le quiero dar entonces la
bienvenida a maria tereza hay es
analista internacional y también
coordinadora de la maestría en asuntos
internacionales de la universidad
externado en colombia maría tereza
gracias por estar normalmente aquí con
nosotros en france 24
buenos días muchas gracias por la
invitación buenos días entonces la
pregunta inicial maria tereza como esto
va a afectar a las elecciones del 21
esta acusación constitucional es
definitivamente un tema político las
elecciones son en 10 días y no hay un
candidato por ejemplo de la coalición de
gobierno del presidente piñera entonces
uno dice tanta acusación
constitucional cuando ya el presidente
no puede ser reelegido de nuevo y su
partido su coalición tampoco está
representada en las elecciones así que
uno dijera bueno vamos en contra de él
entonces se vuelve un tema político en
contra de piñera en contra de una
derecha que tiene que renovarse en
chile- bastante pero que a las
elecciones lo que esto ha hecho en los
últimos seis meses es renovar una
derecha extrema
y eso es lo que se está viendo para las
elecciones ahorita del 21 de noviembre
una derecha extrema que hace cuatro años
no le fue nada bien está surgiendo a
raíz de todos estos movimientos de toda
esta represión de todas estas
acusaciones a la derecha y hay gente que
dice prefiero esto a seguir en este
régimen de acusaciones osa digamos que
ellos entonces lo están haciendo para
afectar a la derecha y pues así que esta
derecha chilena cr9 nuevamente porque
como le estaba diciendo usted sebastián
piñera no puede ser reelegido el partido
se va también a tampoco tiene una
representación entonces es como
simplemente un golpe de este de este
sector de la política a la derecha es un
golpe de la izquierda jackson el que
llegó a votar tarde al que esperaron 20
horas haciendo este acto de filibustero
a la latina que fue muy interesante de
ver
ellos son la izquierda y quieren
realmente tomo que la izquierda sea
dominante en el país esto ha hecho que
la derecha se sienta atacada y reaccione
volviéndose aún más de extrema y esos
son los dos candidatos supuestamente
fuertes en este momento boris por una
izquierda centro izquierda porque él
había además izquierda en su momento
pero la derecha si se fue por la extrema
derecha josé antonio kast es la extrema
derecha en chile
maría tereza antes de seguir analizando
todo este panorama político le quiero
preguntar entonces que sigue
específicamente en la cámara alta con
este caso de sebastián piñera ahora el
caso pasa a la cámara alta o el senado y
ahí no hay el apoyo que tuvo en la
cámara baja en la cámara diputados
necesita cuatro o cinco votos más de los
que tiene la oposición es decir la
derecha los partidos de gobierno la
coalición de gobierno cinco personas se
tienen que voltear y votar en contra el
presidente piñera y esto es bastante
dudoso que pase por varias razones una
están al final del gobierno y no van a
acabar mal ya tienen muy baja la
popularidad ya no vale la pena seguir
echándole leña al fuego la baja
popularidad de acabar con el gobierno
tan mal 2 porque desde las elecciones
tampoco les conviene a ellos decidir
vamos a echarle fuego a la cara estamos
haciendo una nueva constitución pero
estamos haciendo una acción
constitucional basada en las leyes
anteriores entonces seamos coherentes
señores ya dejemos este caso ya el señor
no va a ser presidente dejémoslo por el
bien político por el bien constitucional
por eso el legado que tiene chile de un
país legalista que cree en el derecho
antes que cualquier otra cosa dejémoslo
así entonces la izquierda ahora sí
metiendo las generales llega fortalecida
a este 21 de noviembre que puede pasar
en este panorama electoral que vamos a
ver pronto en chile la izquierda siempre
ha sido fuerte en chile uno piensa en
allende y no 60 años antes ya era fuerte
a la izquierda en chile desde los años
30 y la concertación después los
movimientos de democratización después
del pre de pinochet fueron de izquierda
con excepción de los dos mandatos de
piñera es decir ahora se ha fortalecido
se ha fortalecido con los movimientos
sociales con el movimiento estudiantil
del
principio desde la primera década de
este siglo un movimiento que dio origen
a boris el gran candidato boris tiene el
apoyo de la gente joven de todos
aquellos que creen en la nueva
constitución y se ha fortaleció bastante
hace cuatro años piñera ganó tal vez
porque fue un voto en contra de una
izquierda que estaba poco unida con el
candidato de iu no fue un voto a favor
de piñera han pasado cuatro años y la
gente dice no voy a volver a votar en
contra de algo porque me va a peor que
si voto en contra de que si voto a favor
de otra digamos que el voto castigo es
un castigo para la población exacto yo
creo que así lo están viendo y la
izquierda está fortalecida por otro lado
los que siguen pensando que hay que
votar en contra de se van a ir a los
extremos
hablando ahora maría tereza de esa
constitución producto 1 la demanda
principal digamos de este estado social
de el año 2019 esto también ha
fortalecido de alguna manera al
movimiento de izquierda en chile y fue
otro golpe para la porque recordemos que
sebastián piñera pues también estaba en
el poder y fue acusado también por malos
tratos
a los manifestantes prácticas
incorrectas por parte de la policía que
han hecho una primera acusación
existencial hace dos años y no había
pasado la cámara baja la cámara de
diputados esta vez sí lo hizo esta nueva
constitución que se viene es necesaria
pero ayuda sobre todo a la clase media
chilena el presidente lagos en su
momento cuando le preguntaron
precisamente por estas manifestaciones
dijo chile en las 17 años de la
concertación
sacó a mucha gente de la pobreza y sobre
todo fortaleció pasó de un 20 al 60 por
dar cifras redondas por ciento de la
población a la clase media pero el país
se quedó gobernando como si la clase
media fuera el 20 por ciento el país no
cumplió con las expectativas de este 40
por ciento que había ingresado a la fase
productiva del país de una manera
contundente en este sentido las
manifestaciones
fortalecieron y reivindicaron a ese 40%
esa clase media chilena y esa clase
media chilena que se siente reivindicada
con las manifestaciones se siente
reivindicada con la nueva constitución
con los cambios prometidos y yo pensaría
que reivindicada con esa izquierda que
le está prometiendo el cambio y no con
la derecha que para ellos no les cumplió
llamaría teresa para finalizar que
podemos ver entonces en los próximos
días en chile de cara a estas elecciones
21 y noviembre bueno el senado tiene
seis días para tomar una decisión
y las elecciones son en diez esto yo
creo que la decisión que tome el senado
va a ser una decisión de mano con las
elecciones
si quieren que de alguna manera pueden
ayudar a la derecha al centro derecha
porque esta es una elección una primera
vuelta con varios candidatos seguramente
los cinco senadores que tienen que
voltear se no lo van a hacer
entonces va a ser una decisión política
de cara a las elecciones del 21 de
noviembre y de cara a ver cómo ayudan al
centro derecha derecha o como le quitan
votos a esa izquierda
fortalecida por las manifestaciones